[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend den titel kleines bundesland
hören die saarländer zwar nicht so gerne
aber zumindest die saarländischen grünen
und ihre wähler können froh sein dass
sie nur so wenige sind sonst wäre die
heutige entscheidung des
bundeswahlausschusses für ihre parteien
noch fataler aus dem saarland wird es am
wahlabend jedenfalls keine einzige grüne
zweitstimme geben die partei ist dort
nicht mehr zur wahl zugelassen wegen
grober verfahrensfehler bei der
aufstellung ihrer landesliste dass so
etwas einer etablierten erfahrenen
partei passiert ist vorsichtig gesagt
ziemlich erstaunlich und auch ziemlich
peinlich es gab massive animositäten und
machtkämpfe innerhalb des
landesverbandes sowie zwischen bundes
grünen und teilen der saarländer dabei
müssen wohl einige den kopf verloren
haben verena garrett berichtet
sie hatte gehofft dass der
bundeswahlausschuss eine andere
entscheidung trifft john tillschneider
die nummer eins der grünen landesliste
die bundestagswahl aber wird ohne die
saarländischen grünen stattfinden für
die partei ist halt wirklich ja das
schlimmste was passieren kann überhaupt
nicht auf den wald hätte mit der
zweitstimme gewählt zu werden
hintergrund schwerer streit um die
listenaufstellung hubert ulrich
jahrzehntelang hat er die grünen gelenkt
gilt als strippenzieher spaltet die
partei auf dem parteitag im juni waren
viele delegierte zum ersten mal dabei
handverlesen von ihm schließlich wurde
er zum spitzenkandidaten gewählt aus
protest gab es rücktritte kritik an
seiner aufstellung kam auch aus der
bundes partei von dort gab es druck auf
den landesvorstand später erklärte ein
schiedsgericht die liste für ungültig
das frauen statut der grünen seien nicht
eingehalten worden ulrich sie die schuld
am chaos nicht bei sich schaden hier für
die partei im saarland ist enorm aber
auch der schaden für die bundespartei
ist groß weil die bundesspitze zusammen
mit dem bundesschiedsgericht hier eine
situation herbeigeführt hat die
bundesweit klar macht dass die grünen
die innerparteiliche demokratie nicht
mehr achten hubert ulrich ist sprecher
vom ortsverband saarlouis vor dem
zweiten anlauf hatte das
bundesschiedsgericht der grünen 49
delegierte aus ebendiesem ortsverband
ausgeschlossen der grund bei der wahl
der delegierten wurden
unregelmäßigkeiten festgestellt
die daraufhin erstellte liste immer john
will schneider an der spitze des der
landeswahlausschuss nicht zu der
ausschluss der delegierten sei ein
eklatanter verstoß gegen das
demokratieprinzip
der bundeswahlausschuss kann heute zur
gleichen auffassung ich finde die partei
hätte sehen müssen
in welches problem wir hier hinein
kommen und hätte rechtzeitig
vorkehrungen treffen müssen dass mir
nicht in diese lage hinein kommen als
diese entscheidung fiel war robert
habeck in rheinland pfalz unterwegs
nachdem vor ein paar wochen die vorgänge
im saarland noch öffentlich kommentiert
wurden sind heute fragen zum thema nicht
gestattet mehr als eine moderation rolle
hätte der bundesvorstand im grunde
genommen nie einnehmen sollen dadurch
dass man sich direkt eingemischt hat
auch mit rechtlichen konsequenzen die
sich jetzt daraus ergeben hat man sich
die probleme ein stück weit selber
geschaffen der schaden für alle
beteiligten inklusive bundes partei ist
immens das resultat einer langen
zerreißprobe seit vielen jahren herrscht
an die tiefe kluft zwischen zwei
parteiflügeln jenen die auf der seite
des langjährigen landesvorsitzenden
ulrich stehen und jenen die dagegen sind
und bisher hat es leider noch nicht dazu
geführt dass irgendjemand angefangen hat
brücken zu bauen und jetzt ist auch die
letzte brücke offenbar kaputt gegangen
auf der webseite der saar-grünen steht
beim vorsitz des landesvorstands das
kürzel entnommen dominant der name muss
noch genannt werden ohne führung ohne
liste geht es in den bundestagswahlkampf
schauen wir nach berlin zu theo koll was
sagt denn eigentlich die bundesspitze
der grünen zu der ganzen sache oder
anders gefragt warum es da in berlin so
still heute
nun weil aus sicht der grünen
bundesspitze ihnen das problem jetzt
schon viel zu laut und ja bundesweite um
die ohren geflogen ist die neue
reaktions strategie bei den grünen
könnte man eher mit dem begriff weg
schweigen beschreiben von der
parteispitze kamen heute ja nur dünne
schriftliche erklärung oder es wurde
selbst bei presseterminen eisern
geschwiegen hinter den kulissen
allerdings wurde auf den landesverband
gezeigt der sei verfilzt und kaputt aber
natürlich fällt das ganze jetzt auch
hier der bundes partei schwer auf die
füße der bundeswahlleiter sprach ja
heute davon dass bei der aufstellung der
saarland liste gegen den kernbereich der
demokratischen verfahrensgrundsätze
verstoßen sei das ist ziemlich starker
tobak und ganz sicher der stoff aus dem
im wahlkampf dann ansehensverluste
entsteht auch für die beteiligte bundes
partei
kann sich dann dieser wegfall sozusagen
saarländischen zweitstimmen auf die
bundestagswahl im ergebnis auswirken
sagt ist klein aber ganz ohne ja dann
doch auch nicht ja also das saarland ist
in der tat nicht allzu groß und die
anzahl der wähler ist überschaubar der
ausschluss der saar-grünen muss also
nicht wichtig werden aber er könnte ist
und zwar dann wenn die grünen in die
situation eines kopf-an-kopf-rennens
geraten beispielsweise mit der spd bei
der frage wer bei einer möglichen
ampelkoalition die nummer eins ist und
damit dann auch die kanzlerin oder den
kanzler stellt wir erinnern uns 2002
waren nur 6000 stimmen entscheiden für
den wahl gewinnen und für die frage ob
nun gerhard schröder oder edmund stoiber
kanzler wird 6000 stimmen die saar
grünen hatten bei der letzten
bundestagswahl 2017 über 35.000 stimmen
diesmal hätten dass laut umfragen noch
mehr werden können also sollte das
ergebnis knapp werden dann hätten die
grünen heute mehr verloren als nur die
zweitstimmen aus dem salat danke für die
analyse theo koll
nächstes thema stichwort krone wir
müssen lernen mit dem virus zu leben
hieß es auch in israel die risikogruppen
weitgehend durchgeimpft die
krankenhauseinweisungen waren niedrig
für viele israelis fühlte es sich an als
sei die pandemie im wesentlichen vorbei
und der rest nun ja normales
lebensrisiko
doch die lage hat sich leider geändert
nun werden in israel wieder klassische
anti corona maßnahmen ergriffen und auch
das böse wort lockdown macht wieder die
runde was dort geschehen ist muss uns
interessieren denn israel war und zwar
corona in verschiedener hinsicht immer
einige monate voraus vor allem beim
impfen reif goldmann berichtet aus tel
aviv
die strände sind nicht besonders voll in
diesen tagen in tel aviv den israel es
touristen nur in ausnahmefällen ins land
und verschärft die krone regeln weiter
ab mittwoch gilt für alle einreisenden
eine quarantäne pflicht von sieben tagen
selbst wenn man geimpft ist die masken
pflicht wird ausgeweitet und es soll
wieder mehr home office geben
die wirtschaft und die freiheiten sind
nebensache wichtiger ist es leben zu
retten das ist wie ein flächenbrand wenn
es einmal wieder anfängt dann weißt du
nicht wo es endet
man braucht keine angst haben wir haben
schon ein jahr mit der pandemie
durchgemacht
ich mache mir sorgen weil ich weiß dass
das virus zurück kommen und es bald
einen harten lockdown geben wird wir
gehen jetzt noch aus oder an den strand
und versuchen die zeit die uns noch
bleibt zu nutzen
die zahl der täglichen neuinfektionen
ist in den vergangenen wochen deutlich
gestiegen auf fast 3500 gestern das
entspricht einer inzidenz von 208 auch
die zahl der schweren fälle und
todesfälle steigt und das obwohl fast 60
prozent der bevölkerung doppelt geimpft
sind aber die kampagne stoppt fast
täglich rührt die regierung beim
medientermin und die werbetrommel und
verbreitet heute diese bilder
ministerpräsident bennett trifft sich
mit influenza den israel hat eine extrem
junge bevölkerung und die muss noch
überzeugt werden je jünger desto
geringer die impfbereitschaft
wir könnten mit euren eigenen händen
jeder von euch das ist unfassbar jeder
von euch kann 30 bis 40 menschenleben
retten ich bitte euch das israelische
volk bittet euch zu engagieren
israel macht druck wie wenige andere
auch impft das land inzwischen menschen
über 60 bereits zum dritten mal mit dem
so genau booster aufruf monarchin die
impfungen sind acht monate her und mit
der zeit lässt die wirkung nach deswegen
geben wir den booster um die immunität
zu verstärken vor allem in diesem alter
in dem man viel empfindlicher für ihre
krankheiten ist das ist ein zusätzlicher
schutz für ältere bürger die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hält dagegen
sie ist vom nutzen des boosters noch
nicht überzeugt
das aller wichtigste ist im moment dass
wir uns weltweit auf die menschen
konzentrieren
die immer noch das höchste risiko haben
das sind die die noch nicht einmal eine
erst- oder zweiten führung bekommen
haben in israel aber verweigern nach
schätzungen etwa eine von neun millionen
menschen die impfung von herdenimmunität
ist das land noch weit entfernt und so
rechnen sie hier fast schon wenn die
zahlen mit den neuen einschränkungen
nicht doch noch sinken für september mit
einem neuen hafen lockdown
mir zur krone lage in israel und bei uns
in deutschland finden sie online auf zdf
heute mit dem thema gibt es jetzt auch
bei heinz erstmal noch weiter vor der
bund länder runde zum corona kurs im
herbst und winter geht die debatte über
mögliche neue beschränkungen weiter
gesundheitsminister sparen cdu
verteidigte überlegungen dass bestimmte
beschränkungen bei höheren
infektionszahlen für ungeimpfte gelten
könnten und sagte in einem interview mit
dem münchner merkur für discos stadien
oder theater also bereiche die nicht zur
grundversorgung gehören kann ich mir
auch einen zutritt nur für geimpfte oder
genesene vorstellen zu sparen zu
überlegungen justizministerin lambrecht
von der spd wenn der staat allerdings
eingreift wenn der staat solche
vorschriften macht dann ist das ein
eingriff in zahlreiche grundrechte und
es muss immer verhältnismäßig sein wir
haben momentan eine incidents von 19
bundesweit und da stellt sich schon die
frage ob diese diskussion jetzt die
richtigen sind
die afg kann in bremen und doch mit
einer landesliste zur bundestagswahl
antreten der bundeswahlausschuss gab
einer beschwerde gegen die
nichtzulassung statt der
landeswahlausschuss hatte bemängelt dass
die eidesstattliche erklärung der
schriftführer wenn der wahlversammlung
fehlt habe
im missbrauchs kommt ex von münster hat
der prozess gegen die mutter eines heute
elfjährigen jungen begonnen die 31
jährige soll laut staatsanwaltschaft
gewusst haben dass ihr sohn durch ihren
lebensgefährten mehrfach missbraucht
wurde und ihren sohn nicht geschützt
haben an einzelnen taten soll die mutter
beteiligt gewesen sein ihr drohen bis zu
15 jahre haft die angeklagte bestreitet
die vorwürfe
die europäische union hat den gesandten
von belarus einbestellt wegen des
konflikts um die einschleusung
geflüchtete aus dem irak nach litauen
diese praxis müsse enden erklärte die eu
kommission in brüssel liter und wirft
belarus vor gezielt geflüchtete vor
allem aus dem irak einzuschleusen als
vergeltung für die verhängten
eu-sanktionen wähler wussten machthaber
lukaschenko will nun verhindern dass
migranten aus litauen zurückgeschickt
werden und hat eine teilweise schließung
der grenze angeordnet
die usa werden menschen aus hongkong
zunächst nicht ausweisen oder abschieben
wenn die aufenthaltsgenehmigung
abgelaufen ist us präsident biden
erklärte er wolle einen sicheren
zufluchtsort bieten china hätte den
hongkong an ihre rechte und freiheiten
genommen die behörden in der
sonderverwaltungszone gehen massiv gegen
die demokratiebewegung hongkongs vor
seit vor gut einem jahr das sogenannte
sicherheitsgesetz erlassen wurde seit
monaten demonstrieren tausende bürger
wegen des fliegenden wachsenden einfluss
chinas und hat weltweit gab es empörung
mit dem zerschlagen von
demokratiebewegungen kennt man sich auch
in iran aus das mullah-regime hand
bisher noch immer dafür gesorgt dass es
an der macht bleibt und kritiker mundtot
gemacht werden viele iraner haben
resigniert der einzige ungefährliche
protest wer ihnen noch bleibt ist es
sich bei wahlen zu verweigern bei der
präsidentschaftswahl im juni ging
weniger als die hälfte überhaupt noch
hin viele bewerber waren gar nicht erst
zugelassen worden gewonnen hat dann an
ultra konservative hardliner und heute
hat er seinen amtseid abgelegt
in der tat berichtet
mit gehörigem pomp inszenierte die
teheraner machthaber den amtsantritt von
obama als präsident die stimmung war gut
man ist jetzt praktisch unter sich die
ultra konservativen hardliner
kontrollieren so ziemlich alles was in
der islamischen republik macht
privilegien und freunde verspricht das
parlament die regierung den top job des
revolutionsführers
sei sie soll das land auf kurs bringen
was man sich darunter vorstellen kann
offenbart ein blick in die vergangenheit
des mannes schon als staatsanwalt hatte
er sich in den 80er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts mit tausenden
außergerichtlichen hinrichtungen von
linken oppositionellen den ruf eines
blut richters erworben millionen iraner
fühlen sich jetzt in einer düsteren
zeitschleife gefangen
die islamische republik macht eigentlich
den eigenen bürgern wie dem ausland klar
dass sie das bleibt was sie ist dass sie
weiter im menschenrechte missachten und
ihre politik nicht ändern wird
dass der neue präsident die
katastrophale wirtschaftslage in den
griff kriegen wird daran glaubt auf den
straßen teherans kaum jemand
das brot kostet heute 300 yuan morgen
schon 1000
die herren an der spitze kommen und
gehen nur die probleme bleiben deshalb
erwarte ich auch von herrn reisig eine
wunder
in der firma von hamid reza tahiri hat
machen sich mitarbeiterinnen und der
chef große sorgen seit jahren wird das
business schwieriger software aus dem
ausland auf die sie dringend angewiesen
sind kommt entweder nicht mehr ins land
oder ist nicht mehr bezahlbar
wir stehen vor einer gewaltigen krise
mit düsteren aussichten bislang haben
wir uns immer noch mut gemacht aber im
moment bin ich sehr skeptisch
der neue präsident äußerte sich heute
nur kurz zu seinen außenpolitischen
zielen ganz oben steht die aufhebung der
sanktionen
die sanktionen gegen das iranische volk
müssen weg wir unterstützen jede
diplomatische initiative die zu ihrer
aufregung führt
der publizist jumpy glaubt allerdings
dass sich die außenbeziehungen unter 30
sie weiter verschlechtern werde
sie haben eine politik der
feindseligkeit gegenüber dem ausland
insbesondere dem westen und das werden
sie verschärfen mit allen negativen
wirtschaftlichen folgen für die menschen
us präsident biden rief sie auf die
verhandlungen über das ausgesetzte
nuklear abkommen so schnell wie möglich
wieder aufzunehmen
eigentlich sollte schon zum jahresanfang
der rundfunkbeitrag erhöht werden die
unabhängige fachkommission die den
betrag festlegt hatte einen
entsprechenden vorschlag gemacht doch
sachsen anhalt stellte sich klären als
einziges bundesland und sehr zum ärger
anderer landesregierungen die sache ging
vors bundesverfassungsgericht und das
hat nun entschieden die blockade durch
die regierung eines einzelnen
bundeslandes ist ein verstoß gegen die
rundfunkfreiheit zu der auch gehört dass
die politik keinen finanziellen druck
auf die sender ausüben soll christian
decker und franke berichten
dezember 2020 im landtag von sachsen
anhalt soll über die erhöhung des
rundfunkbeitrages abgestimmt werden doch
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff findet
keine mehrheit deshalb lässt er erst gar
nicht abstimmen und das war ein verstoß
gegen das grundgesetz sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein dilemma so
haseloff heute
dass auf der einen seite
man diesen finanzbedarf zur kenntnis
nehmen darf
und eigentlich nur zustimmen darf wenn
man verfassungskonform handeln will als
parlamentarier ein parlamentarier ein
frei gewählter abgeordneter eines
parlaments allerdings nur seinem
gewissen verpflichtet ist und eine
eigene bewertung
entsprechend vorzunehmen hat diese
dilemma situation löst das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht stellt in
seiner entscheidung klar
erfüllt ein land seine pflicht zur
mitwirkung an der rundfunkfinanzierung
nicht so liegt darin eine verletzung der
rundfunkfreiheit
geplant war den aktuellen
rundfunkbeitrag ab erstem januar 2021 um
86 cent zu erhöhen und so kommt es nun
auch der rundfunkbeitrag steigt
rückwirkend zum 20 erstmal vorläufig das
gericht hebt in seiner entscheidung die
bedeutung des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks gerade in zeiten von fake news
und desinformation hervor die
beschwerdeführer begrüßen die
entscheidung auch das zdf
sie sichert die unabhängigkeit des
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks und
ermöglicht uns auch künftig ein
attraktives programmangebot für alle
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zu machen
kritik an der entscheidung unter anderem
von der afd es ist ein weiterer skandal
urteil des verfassungsgerichtes das muss
man so sagen ist eine schande und es ist
ein tiefschlag gegen unsere föderales
system und gegen die souveränität der
länderparlamente
das gericht dagegen sieht die verfassung
nur dann gewährt wenn der
rundfunkbeitrag auch ohne die zustimmung
von sachsen anhalt nun steigt mit folgen
für die bundesländer sagt die
koordinatorin der rundfunkkommission
wir müssen nicht erneut
landesparlamente damit beschäftigen
sondern es kann jetzt gestartet werden
und ich erwarte dass spätestens zum
jahresende auch dann die
beitragserhöhung von den anstalten
umgesetzt werden wird mit dieser
entscheidung hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht die
rundfunkfreiheit einmal mehr gestärkt
der wald ist ein deutsche sehnsuchtsort
vor allem wenn er so aussieht wie dieser
ein gesunder frisch grüner mischwald
daneben gibt es in deutschland aber ja
auch jede menge bilder die eigentlich
keine sind sondern wirtschafts plantagen
mit großen pflanzen in monokultur dass
sie gegen die zunehmende trockenheit
stürme und borkenkäfer besonders
schlecht gewappnet sind ist inzwischen
allgemein wissen viele wälder sollen
daher möglichst umgebaut werden doch wie
daran scheiden sich die geister die
einen wollen den wald managen etwa mit
gezielten aufforstungen und neuen
baumsorten andere halten das für
grundfalsch sie fördern den wald sich
selbst zu überlassen um zu gesunden und
forstwirtschaft zumal in zeiten in denen
holz schon knapp und teuer ist lässt
sich das aber schwer verein dieser
dissenz wurde heute auch bei einem so
genannten nationalen wald gipfel
deutlich die konferenz soll eine art
alternative gegenveranstaltung zu den
wald gipfeln der bundesregierung sein
susanne gelhard berichtet
förster und buchautor peter wohlleben
ist als wald versteher bekannt jetzt hat
er ein treffen zur rettung des waldes
organisiert einen nationalen wald gipfel
so nennt auch die bundesregierung ihre
wahl treffen doch die hätten wenig
gebracht er habe ein besseres konzept
meint wohl eben
das rezept sieht ganz einfach aus wir
müssen den wald selber machen lassen wir
haben ihn nämlich noch nicht mal richtig
verstanden und so lange dass wir nicht
wie es funktioniert was wir wissen ist
dass selbst organisierende wälder also
die wir in ruhe lassen das noch richtig
gut drauf haben und davon profitieren
das sehen zum beispiel teile der
forstwirtschaft anders tatsache aber ist
noch nie ging es dem deutschen wald so
schlecht inzwischen sind fast 80 prozent
der bäume geschädigt
walderhalt vor wirtschaftlichen ertrag
das ist eine wichtige botschaft der
runde aus wissenschaft klimaschutz
organisationen und vertreter innen von
regierung und opposition
forstwirtschaft soll ja ihren raum haben
ich sage nur nicht mehr holz aus dem
wald nehmen als dass der wald es
vertragen kann also wenn wir so stark
einschlagen dass der weit dadurch in den
nächsten jahren in die binsen geht da
ist nichts gewonnen was wo lieben
fordert setzen die förster am donnerstag
in rheinland-pfalz längst um sie
entwickeln bereits ihren wald der
zukunft eher bedeckt schon die hälfte
des reviers kein kahlschlag eine
aufforstung mehr und dort wo der bestand
geschädigt ist soll sich der wald selbst
erneuern naturverjüngung heißt das
sie sehen wir hier in diesem
wildschutzzaun hier hier hier überall
einen naturfilm das ist für uns auch
eine positive entwicklung aber
das dauert ja also bis die branche 02
meter hoch sind gehen schon 20 jahre ins
land von diesem regen sommer profitieren
vor allem die kleinen triebe viele große
bäume sind verloren sie schaffen es
einfach nicht mehr sie zu ersetzen ist
eine aufgabe von generationen
wir brauchen auf jeden fall mehr wald
der bisschen zeit bekommt und raum das
ist entscheidend und dann geht es gar
nicht jetzt um die frage welche bäume
wachsen da drin im moment haben wir noch
eine relativ große artenvielfalt von
bäumen die sich auch in den derzeitigen
extremen zeiten ganz gut schlagen wald
heilen wald schützen darum geht es dem
heutigen gipfel eine große aufgabe für
die zukunft
nach dem heute-journal update führt anna
maria schuck dazu dann noch ein
interview mit peter wohlleben und jetzt
macht erst noch ein zweiter mit
wirtschaft und den schäden durch
zunehmendes cyberangriffe es gibt dazu
eine neue studie des digital verbandes
bitkom stéphanie barrett welche
dimension haben diese cyber attacken
eine immense cyberangriffe erschüttern
unternehmen aller branchen und größen in
deutschland fast die gesamte wirtschaft
systeme werden verschlüsselt und der
geschäftsbetrieb lahmgelegt kunden und
geschäftsdaten geklaut all das kostet
die unternehmen im vergangenen jahr
unglaubliche
223 milliarden euro doppelt so viel wie
im vorjahreszeitraum und aktuell sieht
sogar jedes zehnte unternehmen seine
geschäftliche existenz durch cyber
attacken bedroht kein wunder seit corona
läuft die digitalisierung der wirtschaft
auf hochtouren kriminelle sehen eine
zusätzliche möglichkeit für angriffe und
auch home office ist ein zusätzliches
einfallstore für hacker angriffe
unzureichend geschulte mitarbeiter die
mit einem falschen klick hacker ins
firmen system lassen sind laut bitkom
mit 42 prozent bereits ein hohes risiko
für cyberattacken gefolgt von hackern
und organisierter kriminalität die
drastischen zahlen dürften letzter
weckruf für unternehmer sein niemand
kann sich da wegducken das erklärte
bitkom chef achim berg heute in berlin
viele firmenlenker haben den ernst der
lage bereits erkannt und investieren das
thema ist vielfach bereits chefsache
darüber hinaus muss aber die digitale
kompetenz der mitarbeiter verbessert und
auch schlicht für regelmäßige updates
gesorgt werden gemessen an den finalen
milliarden-schäden eine weitaus
preiswertere lösung
stephanie beckert vielen dank im
mittelmeerraum gibt es weiterhin
zahlreiche wald- und buschbrände der
griechische regierungschef mit zutage
sprach von einer nie dagewesenen
umweltkrise einsatzkräften ist es
gelungen die antiken olympischen stätten
auf der halbinsel peloponnes vor den
flammen vorerst zu schützen auf der
insel euböa und am stadtrand von athen
wüten weiterhin mehrere brände die
anhaltende hitzewelle und starke winde
sollen in den kommenden tagen die feuer
weiter anfachen und löscharbeiten
erschweren
ähnliche bedingungen herrschen in der
türkei allein in der provinz mugla
mussten mehr als 36.000 menschen in
sicherheit gebracht werden in italien
sind sizilien und kalabrien besonders
betroffen der zuständige minister geht
bei den brandursachen mehrheitlich von
brandstiftung aus
das war es von uns beiden und gleichen
nach dem heute-journal stellen sich
spd-kandidat olaf scholz und cdu
fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus dem zdf
wahlduell für und wider und um 0.40
meldet sich dann an dem rallye schub mit
unserem heutigen update
[Musik]
schon gut und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter sie erinnern sich vielleicht an
die enorme hitze über nordamerika im
juli und diese hitze die hatte ich
regelrecht auf unserer klima karte
manifestiert bis an die 50 grad ging es
ja und sie sehen hier über nordamerika
tatsächlich rötliche farbe also hier ist
die temperaturabweichung sehr groß und
auch über europa vor allem im osten war
es sehr warm und teilweise bis nach
skandinavien aber im westen europas
inklusive teils südwestlichen
deutschlands war es sogar zu kühl und
weltweit ist das der drittwärmste juli
zusammen mit dem juli aus dem
vergangenen jahr und europaweit sogar
der zweitwärmste schauen wir auf die
wetterlage die ist recht eingefahren
immer noch die tiefs die uns beehren und
sie sehen hier dieses band das gehört zu
einer kaltfront was morgen heftige
gewitter auslösen wird ja und aus dem
südwesten erreicht weiterhin heiße luft
griechenland und die türkei in der nacht
verschwinden die gewitter im südosten
von südwesten her kommen neuer auf und
das bei tiefsten temperaturen von zehn
grad in den östlichen landesteilen und
15 grad ganz im westen sowie an den
küsten und morgen tagesverlauf ist die
kaltfront quer über uns teils mit
starkregen hagel und sturmböen
von südwesten her lockert es wieder auf
mit sonnenschein und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von 24 bis 25 grad im
westen 19 grad am samstag kommen neue
schauer von westen her auf teils mit
kräftigen gewitter temperaturen bis 27
grad ein schöner abend